more from the boys of BTS and their
world tour plans plus battle of the exes
I'm talking selena and Justin the
weekend and Bella Hadid hello everyone
I'm Danny direct oh and this is the
daily Deni
I'm reintroducing myself because we have
some new friends of the show thanks to
the BTS army I've read most of your
guys's tweeting you are seriously the
nicest fans and like I mentioned
tomorrow we have the band answering the
questions you guys sent us but today
I've got something to hold you over
allowing you wanted to know which
countries they will tour and I asked
here's what they said when we talked you
guys back in September RM you teased
that you guys have plans to come back to
the US for a world tour in 2018 what can
you tell us about that so for short we
will visit I think more cities and I
think we'll definitely be like you know
like adding like more performance and
more stages so I don't know like the
particular time when we will be coming
back but you know but it's definitely
gonna be like doper and it's gonna have
a go
yeah and really happen there's fans all
over the world that want to know if you
guys are gonna be in their City I do
have plans for Europe tour or maybe in
Brazil as well all around the world yeah
of course we just finished our this tour
like named wings and I think it's it's
gonna be there's gonna be like new
series for the tour so like of course
including United staes like mmm like
it'll happen I think I hope that it'll
happen everywhere every content
absolutely they want it they were they
were tweeting I wanted sue the u.s. fans
wanna know will you guys ever do a album
in English our fans already know but
we're releasing our new song mic drop
Phoenix with Steve Aoki and designer so
like next week it's gonna be something
like English version of something so I
think we'll try some some versions like
that later any plans for any solo
projects I know a lot of people want to
know about Jay hopes mixtape oh it's
comin coming soon wait a minute I can't
wait to see what hair color for your
mixtape yeah it'll be different right
there there will be like a huge surprise
travel yeah yeah I know
annual plans for any other solo projects
okay he's got one he's got his studio
room yeah just got his new room yeah I
started to produce some beads so maybe
we can't expect some alright alright
okay we're waiting we're ready I'm
waiting - yeah whilst you guys want to
work with who else are you dying to
collaborate with Joe goop can I guess
Justin Bieber yeah let you guys up
who doesn't love Justin Bieber huh no
one jong-kook loves the beads the guy
said they would also want to work with
Daniel Cesar Drake and me goes but I
want BTS and JB to get together huh
alright now speaking of Justin Bieber
seems as though he and Selena Gomez are
officially back on that's right after
spending so much time together the last
few weeks Selena was spotted at Justin's
weekly hockey game where they were
caught kissing so what's the deal while
a source tells ET Selena and Justin are
exclusive quote they've both grown a lot
over the years and are excited to have
reconnected as for what friends think
well Justin definitely had to prove
himself to regain their trust they can
see this time is different
okay but how's this for a little plot
twist just four weeks ago Selena was
still dating the weekend and now it
looks like he is also back with his ex
Bella Hadid we're told he's hanging out
with Bella because a Bella will take him
back and be it's his way of getting back
at Selena for going back to Justin oh ma
and I secretly lived right by our source
says the weekends tactic isn't exactly
working though we're told Selena is
quote completely over it and has moved
on with her life and is in a really
great place
oh boy what do you guys think of this
rebound roulette I mean we should all be
so lucky to find our one true love am i
right which is why I just have to
quickly give a shout-out to my
grandparents who are watching this happy
anniversary you guys have been married
for 49 years and are definitely a
10-plus on the John and Chrissy scale I
love you guys all right thanks for
watching everybody be sure to turn your
notifications on so you don't miss
tomorrow's
Q&A with BTS and I'll see you guys dead